we would now like to apply the momentum
principle to analyze the motion of the
rocket so what is our momentum principle
we know that the external force at time
T is equal to the rate of change of the
momentum of the system over T now recall
we're going to actually use the formal
definition of a derivative to write this
as a limit as delta T goes to 0 of the
momentum of the system at time T plus
delta T minus the momentum of the system
at time T divided by delta T so in order
to analyze the rocket what we need to do
is separately analyze the momentum at
our two states so we have a state at
time T and we have a state at time T
plus delta T and our goal will be to
analyze the system momentum at time T
and separately the system momentum at
time T plus delta T and then we can
apply the momentum principle so let's
begin by analyzing the system at time T
so recall that at that time we had our
rocket and this is our time T and the
rocket had a velocity V of R of T and
what we identified the mass M R of T
recall this was the mass the dry mass of
the rocket and the mass of the fuel and
so now it's very simple to write down
the momentum of our system at time T
that's equal to just the mass ml R of T
times the velocity of the rocket at time
T and so we can use that in our
expression for the momentum of the
system now our next step
is to consider the system at time T T
plus delta-t
now recall we still had the rocket but
the mass the rocket has changed that's
inside the rocket so this is dry mass of
the rocket plus mass of the fuel but
recall some of the fuel has been ejected
outwards so how do we depict that in our
momentum diagram well let's just
symbolize that by a certain amount and
we're going to call this delta and fuel
now what we need to do again is to have
our velocities so here the velocity of
the rocket is now the velocity at time T
plus delta T and what about the velocity
of this fuel that's being ejected well
in our problem the fuel is ejected at
our speed at a velocity u relative to
the rocket so what we have is U is the
velocity of the fuel relative to the
rocket but we've been choosing the
ground frame as our reference frame and
the rocket is moving at a velocity at
time T plus delta T with respect to that
ground frame and so recall that the
velocity of the fuel in the ground frame
is equal to the velocity relative to the
rocket plus the speed of the rocket with
respect to the ground frame and that's
what we're gonna draw on our diagram as
the fuel and so now we can finish this
analysis before and we'll apply that
next is to write the momentum of the
system at time T plus delta T now this
is going to have two terms it has the
mass of the rocket at time T plus delta
T times the velocity of the rocket
and we also have to add mass of the fuel
times the velocity you'll with respect
to the ground and now we have the
momentum at time T plus delta-t so we
have both of our pieces here and we
still have a little bit of analysis
because we'll use our mass conservation
equation to end our relative velocity
condition to simplify this expression so
we'll do that next